Buen día Ángela la dieron desde
diferentes flancos la sorpresa porque no
se esperaba que el tribunal supremo
electoral entregara resultados Tan
pronto se tenía pronosticado que fueran
los resultados finales emitidos hasta
cinco o seis días después de los
comicios pero un día después ya se tiene
certeza de que va a ser Bernardo Arévalo
y Sandra Torres Pues los dos candidatos
que pasen a la segunda vuelta otra de
las sorpresas también pues claramente
fue el apoyo que se le dio desde los
guatemaltecos hacia los no partidos
tradicionales porque es que Bernardo
Arévalo representa el movimiento semilla
que es un partido político que nace
desde el seno de la anticorrupción nace
cuando Guatemala se destacaba
mundialmente en la década del 2010 como
un ejemplo anticorrupción eran los
tiempos de la Sisi la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad en
Guatemala y ahí es donde nace el
movimiento semilla un movimiento
izquierda socialdemócrata social liberal
que además es ecologista completamente
disímil a todos los otros partidos
tradicionales que oscilan entre el
centro y la extrema derecha la extrema
derecha por ejemplo de Suri Ríos o la
centro derecha de edmon mulet que fueron
esos dos candidatos que también dieron
la sorpresa de no quedar entre los tres
más opcionados como las encuestas y los
diferentes sondeos habían vaticinado de
manera que sí se puede llegar a ser un
análisis de cómo El guatemalteco votó
por una opción completamente diferente a
las tradicionales también diferente a la
que proponía el continuismo del partido
vamos de Manuel Conde de Alejandro
yamatei Y entonces a partir de ahora
pues se hacen los números se hacen las
apuestas para ver si Sandra Torres o
Bernardo Arévalo llegará al Palacio
Nacional
Andrés qué podemos esperar de la campaña
de Cara a esta segunda vuelta para el 20
de agosto
bueno para este día y para lo que resta
de aquí hasta el 20 de agosto se van a
formular diferentes alianzas uno de los
más importantes porcentajes de las
votaciones de ayer fue el del voto nulo
el voto nulo
teniéndolo en cuenta fue el que ganó los
comicios porque obtuvo más del 17% de
los votos es decir estuvo por encima de
Sandra Torres por encima de Bernardo
Arévalo y ese voto nulo También estaría
diciendo o haciendo sentir el desencanto
el descontento de Guatemala con estos
comicios porque El guatemalteco
encuestaba en la calle dice que no más
que ya está harto de lo mismo del que se
denomina el pacto de corruptos esa
Alianza o esa amalgama entre
los que detentan el poder entre los
funcionarios acusados de corrupción en
las diferentes instituciones el voto
nulo podría ir con Bernardo Arévalo y
los partidos de derecha o de extrema
derecha podrían aliarse con Sandra
Torres